[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
tonight the Academy honors women and the
movies that's very nice but I look
forward to the time when tributes like
this will no longer be necessary
[Applause]
it won't be necessary because women will
have the same opportunities as men in
all fields and will be honored without
regard to gender but simply for the
excellence of their work
a time when there couldn't possibly be a
year of the woman because there will be
so many in prominent positions this
award is not for a woman director or a
man director this award is for the Best
Director and it is my privilege to
present it tonight the nominees are Neil
Jordan for The Crying Game
James ivory for Howard Zinn
Robert Altman for the player
Martin dressed for several women Clint
Eastwood for Unforgiven
[Music]
and the Oscar goes to Clint Eastwood
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Pacino's throat was dry mine's really
dry to sit here all this time is fed I
just this is pretty good this is all
right yeah
I've been I've been around for 39 years
and I I've really enjoyed it I've been
very lucky i heard al say he was lucky
but everybody feels that way when you're
able to make a living in a profession
that you really enjoy that's an
opportunity i think a lot of people
don't have I got to thank the crew the
David Valdez and and Jack green and all
like all the camera crew the ho the
trouble is with living this long as you
know so many people and you can't
remember their names I tell you get he
get a little flustered so but in the
year of the woman I'd like to salute the
women a big whiskey and that that would
be anatomists Fisher and Lisa and Tara
and and Josie and Beverly and and all
the gals who really were the catalyst to
get in this story off the ground and
David people's fabulous script the
Warner Brothers for sticking with this
film the film critics for for
discovering this film it wasn't a highly
doubtful when it came out but they sort
of stayed with it throughout the year
the French film critics who embraced
some of my work very early in the game
the British Film Institute the Museum of
Modern Art and some of the people that
were there long before I ever became
fashionable Lenny Hirsch an my agent I'm
leaving out a whole mess of people that
I'm gonna regret when I sit down again
so anyway thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]